I picked up my life and I uprooted
myself I've never lived anywhere other
than California so my hometown
everything that was safe to me um I no
longer felt faced I wasn't I wasn't in a
good place
I'd say myself Ashley Jacobs getting
candid about her relationship with
former southern charm star Thomas
Ravenel it was extremely lonely because
I didn't have the support of my family
they were very disappointed in my
decision so the only person I had was
was Thomas he was my support system and
we were really we were in the trenches
together but it was just it was dark I
lost a lot of weight I I wasn't taking
care of myself mentally I suffered from
depression dating Thomas has taken a
toll I mean when I met her she was a
sweet innocent lovely woman and now I
feel like she's been hurt she's you know
just in kind of a mess safe to say that
Eliza's assessment that dating Thomas
took a toll on you it did right I mean
if you're dating someone and there's
allegations can imagine just that in
itself then you had custody and then you
eat you're adding the children you show
your yes and two people just in a
relationship just trying to you know we
were still trying to trying to figure it
out what do you have to say to people
who assume you got with Thomas because
he was on a reality show and that you
followed him across the country to be on
the show idlife I didn't say that there
was some element of it that was
fascinating
there was intrigued it was different you
know makes good stories and and not a
lot of people can say that they've done
that in their life I was like I wonder
if I you know could do that and there
was a part it could this work cuz if I'm
gonna take my life up and start over
I don't you know I don't get this time
back again and so I need to make sure
that I see a potential I see a future I
don't want to waste my time with
somebody and when I met him I was
actually going to transfer to another
hospital in Vegas all places I've got
family so you were looking for a life
change way regardless okay yes okay yes
I was looking for a life change and I
was I went back a few times a visit him
I thought you know could I make this
work
this is a great town I'm a registered
nurse I can work wherever I want at some
point I thought no I can make my living
get a job out here yes okay I know
someone who has an in not into the
reality TV show but it hasn't in into a
town where I can kind of sit back and
let him take me around and show me
around and the best places to live the
best eat and I like this person so you
were falling for him and there was the
excitement of a new city new job yes all
the things you were looking for at one
time yeah with this package yes he said
you know you could go to Vegas and this
probably won't work out or you could try
this and this might not work out but you
can always go back to Vegas but you not
always gonna get this opportunity so I
followed my heart and I thought you know
what what do I have to lose okay look
here I got a couple please Dylan Thomas
what not well - just dive right into it
she's always sum up worst year of my
life when did you and Thomas call it off
for good I would say in February of this
year so I wouldn't say that we were
necessarily together but again he was my
best friend and my support
we both agree that the best thing for me
to do was to go back home and he he was
the first one to say it so it's old we
still talk of course okay yeah is it
done romantically for good or is that
door still open or done for good done
for go yes I realized that I needed to
find something you have made a friend in
somebody who knows this group very well
in Landon Clements oh yeah
can you explain to me how you two
connected and what your relationship is
because you were never in Charleston
together no in this group together no
that's like Eskimo sisters we never did
anything with him it wasn't anything
weird like we're both dating the same
guy at all
although Thomas where's she gonna dated
her yeah Landon his heart cuz we didn't
we never film together but there's a
support that I had she knows this world
she does she did have some insight and
that's why we connected but she's also a
really fun girl and she's become one of
my friend cuz now she lives in Santa
Barbara right yes I know down the street
from me the world is very sad a mile we
do things that are just good for the my
body and soul and and that's really what
I needed coming back with to get to a
good place and you know emotionally
mentally and physically and so she's
just by chance there and she wants to
all the same things I do so she's the
kind of sister when I was in Charleston
the cast said they thought maybe you
would come back to Charleston at some
point I had even heard rumblings that
maybe when the show started airing you
were gonna move back you have no plans
to move back to Charleston yeah I
haven't had a mosquito bite in about
seven months so I'm really good I'm so
good I am so good it left such a bad
taste in my mouth
really there's some trauma related to it
as much as I still see looking back at
pictures I think it what a beautiful
place I still can't help but feel that
really sad lonely depressed person what
do you hope the next phase of your life
looks like I think the thing that I see
a lot in social media social media is
really good it really makes you really
makes you things but I see the way that
I treated Catherine I get a lot of
comments like you know you'll be a
terrible mother or I hope you'll never
be a mother if your mother you'll
understand you know and people all right
I'm
mother so I can't I can't understand but
I really want that for myself too and I
hope that that's next in my future is my
own family and with the right person of
course and someone who doesn't watch
southern charms it's the bird of it
that's my that's my fear actually is
they don't date me because like just
don't Google me just don't go go me so
maybe I should put off dating until you
know the dust settle then I'm no longer
relevant and you know I'm not
you can't Google me so I don't know how
long that'll be
but maybe just stay off social media
something my friend my mouth but I I
don't know it's in the works
I'm hoping to you know to anything you
know like I said I'd met Thomas rapping
on a bar one day and then too long ever
I'm I'm not too much direction yes so
but I yeah I definitely want my own
family for sure
[Applause]
you